foreign
why do we hold on to these things that
we don't want
it has something to do with the cost of
letting it go and living in a different
world yes because I think back to like
when I was
raised Jehovah's Witness I loved knowing
how the world worked how do we get here
let me tell you
why are we here right now oh I got
answers for that
you want to know where we're going
you each get your own planet right yeah
right exactly that's that's the other
religion oh yeah sorry but but the thing
like when I was disconnecting from that
though it was very difficult because
when when you have an understanding of
how the world works and we all want that
um and when you're so sure about it and
then it and then it starts to crumble a
little bit it's like I I had a choice it
was like do I go even you know go more
all in with it or do I like start to let
it unravel a little bit and to go more
all in was very tempting
it's like picking up more of those rocks
yeah yeah
um so you know what religion or not
political whatever situation people
are choosing to make themselves
miserable in it has it has to do with I
think
that's their world view and to to look
at it any other way is risking
their
it's it's risking them being right like
they they don't want to be no one wants
to be wrong about how they look at the
world view so if they start to look at
it in a different way they are giving up
that certainty and if they've been wrong
the whole time because I went through it
I mean at 25 years old I'm like
like I have been like just bullshitting
me and everyone else for the last 25
years it's hard to admit that
yeah you know this is why
we have to be so careful with trying to
change other people
even if we are convinced that the advice
we have for them is better than the
ideas they're currently acting on I'm
not saying you can never exercise
influence but you got to be very careful
because people's ideas are not just
these theoretical beliefs they have
they're not just answers that they would
give on a philosophy test or a theology
exam people's worldview holds their
whole self together they build their
family life around these World Views
their daily routines around these World
Views and if you take something away
from someone
what are you going to replace that with
and people have to grow and evolve in
their own time and at their own pace not
because your ideas you want to influence
what them with don't matter but because
everyone needs to go at a different pace
with integrating new insights into their
world view because if you ask someone to
change too quickly you might destroy
them there is no such thing as a piece
of advice that is so good that it can't
be abused or misapplied in a way that
actually makes your life worse and
that's why we have to be careful related
I saw a friend on Facebook posts the
following I'm going to paraphrase it
because I can't quote it but he says
something to the effect of
I got together with a friend of mine the
other day and this friend is someone who
claims to be religious but sometimes I
see him living in ways that are not
consistent with his religion and there
are other days I see him living in a
very Noble and devout way
and I had a moment where I wanted to
call him out on it but I also knew that
if he discovers the truth for himself
and sees it for himself he'll be more
likely to make the improvements so
instead I looked at him I told him that
I loved him and I asked him if I could
pray with him and after that I winked at
him and decided to walk away from the
mirror
[Applause]
well thank you all for coming today
let's open it up for some questions
I see him Alabama roaming somewhere
where is she she's sneaking in the back
hi everybody ladies and gentlemen
Alabama
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free